welcome to china's coal country
the impact of all this isn't just being
felt here but by the planet itself
coal is the dirtiest fossil fuel around
and china burns more of it than the rest
of the world combined and it's speeding
up
we've taken a road trip to shenshi
province north china to understand it
better
it's a place where almost everything is
caked in grime and soot but it's the
scale that's astonishing
we visit three coal power plants within
a few hours drive of each other
they're under construction or adding
extra power and between them alone
represent more coal power than the
entire uk output
and what's more they nearly weren't
built
they were all halted a few years ago
under a national directive to restrict
coal power only to resume construction
what this is is zombie coal power killed
off back in 2017 but now being brought
stumbling back to life ready to spew
harmful gases into the air and china
can't or won't kill it off for good
ningwoo town is attached to one of the
mines and heavily reliant on the
industry
people are too busy trying to survive
the coming winter to even know about
cop26
i'm waiting here by school because more
people pass
whole family sells coal my son my
daughter and i we've sold coal our whole
lives
fanlau sir buys coal from nearby mines
then drives into town to sell it from
the back of his van to people here to
burn for heat
because of shortages and coal being
diverted to heavy industry mines have
less to spare sometimes he now has to
wait two days at mine to fill up his van
we asked him what he thought of china's
climate emission targets and cop 26.
which is
i don't know i'm busy every day i earn
my living by working outside all day
long
even chinese climate experts don't
believe it's practical for the country
to cut its co-dependence in the short
term
um
this isn't about the gap between pledges
and reality between high level
international summits and the truth on
the ground
this is the pledge the one china has
made officially to build more and more
coal power for the next four years and
then reduce it only gradually
they've not said how they will do that
or how long it will take
and in that uncertainty that hesitation
hangs the future of our climate tom
cheshire sky news shanxi china